pretty hectic first day of school it's
also important for students and staff
just to find some calm at ruby duncan
elementary it's always available and
this morning ron futrell was there
okay so we're at ruby duncan elementary
school here got something called the zen
then this ought to be interesting to see
exactly what this is i have some idea i
know what zin means like it means
relaxation meditation but this is a room
where students can come to first of all
if there is let out some frustration oh
they have a little boxing area right
here where you can do that if you want
and some trampolines to jump on we
actually saw dr jara come here and he
spent a little time relaxing on the
hammock i sort of think he enjoyed that
hammock
every single community
and every zip code needs and should have
something where they can be able to
reset this is a great space for students
it gives them an environment where it's
a safe area they can come express their
emotions they can talk with our staff
and get their mind ready so they're able
to learn and they're ready to go back
into the classroom in a quick manner
okay now it's important to note there's
also a positive side to this as well
right you can come in here and enjoy
things like this these old they used to
be lava lamps when i was younger okay
but kids get rewarded if they do good
things they get to come in here relax
in the zen den from ruby duncan
elementary ron futrell live local now